et ce soir dans son allocution jean
castex à nouveau encouragé le
télétravail mis en place dès le 1er
confinement est déjà autorisé par la loi
ils s'installent etd travail encore plus
dans nos vies professionnelle et privée
il a d'abord provoqué l'enthousiasmé
beaucoup pointent aujourd'hui ses
inconvénients
alors le télétravail véritable progrès
ou bien danger pour les salariés la
butte télétravail nuit-il à la santé on
en parle tout de suite avec un autre
économiste jacques sapir bonsoir jacques
bonsoir c'est fini alors c'est donc une
des conséquences de la crise sanitaire
un l'essor de ce télétravail pas trop
malheureux de devoir télé travailler
avec nous d'ailleurs jacques ça vous
concerne derrière votre ficus devenue
célèbre souris bercy le coup noro bas je
prends mon mal en patience
alors oui vous avez tout à fait raison
le coc vide lakovic 19 n'a pas créé le
télétravail mais elle a
incontestablement contribué à leur
répondre de manière à tout à fait
considérable ainsi il y avait 4 % des
salariés qui avaient recours au
télétravail
avant la crise sanitaire et il y en a eu
pratiquement 1 sur 4 pendant le premier
confinement alors au départ ce qui est
intéressant c'est que pratiquement les
trois quarts des français qui étaient en
télétravail était très heureux de le
faire entre leucate disait que cela leur
convenait bien et c'était la même chose
du point de vue des entreprises
si vous voulez les entreprises voyaient
que le télétravail pourrait être
l'occasion pour elle de réduire leur
loyer prévu après le fantasme de lusine
cents ouvriers et bien on avait le
fantôme de l'entreprise de bureaux sans
bureaux alors en définitif ce
télétravail qui concerne qu il alors
vous avez tout à fait raison de poser
cette question est et s'il voulait c'est
un des premiers problèmes auxquels on
est confrontés en réalité on voit que le
télétravail
il est extrêmement concentré sur
certaines régions on le voit par exemple
pour le premier confinement alors au
boulot
je vous le redis la moyenne des
travailleurs s'étaient 24 % des
travailleurs qui étaient en télétravail
or qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit qu'ils
étaient 44% dans la région ile de france
c'est tout à fait considérable
al'inverse ils sont évidemment beaucoup
moins nombreux dans d'autres régions
comme les pays de loire les hauts de
france ou la normandie
donc ça prouve qu'il y a une très grande
disparité entre régions sur cette
question du télétravail alors il est
clair jacques que toutes les professions
ne se prête pas de la même manière on en
sait quelque chose au télétravail oui
c'était une évidence
on comprend bien que le télétravail n'a
pas vraiment sa place dans l'industrie
dans le bâtiment évidemment dans la
construction bon mais il n'a pas non
plus sa place dans des professions qui
implique un contact personnel par
exemple ou une présence physique le cas
des transports évidemment mais aussi le
cas de l'agriculture voire du commerce
de proximité
en fait ce sont essentiellement les
travailleurs du tertiaire qui sont
concernés alors une yat-il jacques un
lien entre la taille de l'entreprise et
l'importance du télétravail oui tout à
fait c'est quelque chose que l'on a
remarqué alors même si c'est de manière
intime indirects on a vu effectivement
que le télétravail se développe et
surtout dans des entreprises de taille
moyenne ou de petite taille
alors quand je dis que c'est un un
indicateur induits c'est que on a un
consulter un petit peu des statistiques
un qui regarde la demande en nouveaux
outils numériques par exemple les
logiciels de téléconférence et bien ce
qu'on a vu c'est que le nombre de
travailleurs qui ont eu besoin de
s'équiper avec ces nouveaux outils
il est effectivement beaucoup plus
important dans les entreprises disons de
taille moyenne entre 250 et 1000 et
émile salariés alors qu'est ce que ça
nous donne ça nous donne un portrait
type en fait du télétravailleur 1 c'est
une femme ou un homme travaillant dans
le tertiaire
employé dans une entreprise plutôt de
taille moyenne de plusieurs dizaines
voire de plusieurs centaines de
personnes
10dans essentiellement ou en région
parisienne ou dans une grande métropole
comme lyon marseille ou strasbourg
alors la question quels avantages trouvé
ton au télétravail lors de ce premier
confinement là aussi c'est d'un point
intéressant c'est que il ya eu des
plusieurs études un utile et une en
france des études internationales
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que de
ce point de vue là les travailleurs eux
ils voyaient dans le télétravail tout
d'abord une manière je dirais
d'améliorer la gestion de leurs horaires
ou de pouvoir avoir un cadre travail de
travail plus agréable que le bureau par
exemple pour les entreprises
c'était plutôt les avantages qui
concernait la réduction des dépenses
quotidiennes pour l'entreprise voir un
accroissement apparent de la
productivité seulement avec la fin du
premier confinement les opinions ont
commencé à se réajuster et ça c'est un
point qui est extrêmement intéressant en
fait au début du mois d'octobre dernier
c'est au moment où on a commencé à se
reposer la question d'un possible un
confinement
eh bien on s'est aperçu que le nombre de
travailleurs qui étaient en télétravail
et des as et de 24 % à 14 % dont en fait
seulement 4 % avaient recours de manière
intégrale c'est ya cinq jours par
semaine au télétravail
il y avait donc eu un recul très net de
ce que le premier ministre jan cas secte
avaient un peu imprudemment qualifié de
phénomène de société ou de révolution
dans la manière de travailler
et pourquoi ce changement alors il tout
récent de regarder les raisons qui ont
amené les entreprises à prendre un petit
peu de distance justement avec cette
question du télétravail a tout d'abord
les responsables se sont mis à craindre
que malgré des systèmes informatiques
intrusif qui sont parfois utilisés de ne
pas pouvoir contrôler leurs salariés
vous savez ce n'est pas un hasard si les
open space se sont multipliées dans les
bureaux depuis une vingtaine d'années
les open space
ils ont pour fonction d'organiser le
contrôle sur les salariés
après les entreprises se sont rendu
compte
avec le télétravail elle perdait cette
capacité qu'avait leurs salariés de se
rencontrer d'échanger des idées de
pouvoir même cédé pour effectuer
certaines tâches afin les entreprises
ont réalisé que le télétravail pourrait
aussi avoir des conséquences néfastes à
la fois sur l'innovation et sur la
productivité des salariés
alors on comprend effectivement alors
pourquoi les entreprises à son sont plus
grandes sont prudentes mais n'y at il
pas aussi des réticences du côté des
salariés
oui oui vous avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie en fait on voit qu'il y à
plusieurs risques qui sont apparus pour
les salariés avec cette extension du
télétravailleur premier risque
évidemment c'est le risque d'isolement
social c'est aussi le risque est lié au
fait que le télétravail fait disparaître
la frontière entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie privée du
salarié
et puis il ya ensuite l'ensemble des
risques qui sont induits par là la
pression sur le salarié lié aux
objectifs des objectifs qui d'ailleurs
ne peuvent plus être discuté aussi
facilement qu'au bureau enfin ça semble
assez évident mais visiblement les gens
l'ont redécouvert il ya tous les
problèmes matériels liés à l'équipement
informatique du travailleur lié aussi à
l'espace dont on dispose de chez soi
pour pouvoir travailler
il est clair que ces conditions
matérielles joue beaucoup aujourd'hui
dont le ressenti par rapport au
télétravail et pourtant ces questions
ont fait l'objet d'un accord récent oui
tout à fait tout est fait c'est fini ces
problèmes ont eu un début de
reconnaissance avec l'accord qui a été
signé le 27 novembre dernier entre les
organisations patronales et des
organisations syndicales c'est un accord
qui vise en particulier à prévenir le
harcèlement du salarié par son employeur
mais cet accord n'est en fait que le
début de la reconnaissance des problèmes
liés au télétravail donc il faudra aller
nettement plus loin et puis et puis il
ya quand même un gros problème c'est
qu'il faut le savoir
les problèmes qui sont liées justement
au télétravail
eh bien il donne enfin dix ans il donne
naissance à une interrogation quant à la
santé des travailleurs
et pourquoi ces interrogations alors là
encore c'est une chose intéressante et
où on peut croiser des données qui
viennent d'études canadiennes d'études
qui ont été faites sur la france on voit
très bien qu'il ya eu des problèmes
alors entre ce que j'avais cité comme
l'isolément ou le chevauchement entre la
vie privée et la vie professionnelle
il ya aussi la montée des tensions au
sein des équipes
une fois que son passé en télétravail
pourquoi parce que on s'est rendu compte
que la communication par voix d'écran
favorise justement cette montée des
conflits par yann étudier des fêtes
parra cabinet d'expertisé français le
cabinet syndex qui montrait d'ailleurs
que la crise avait amplifié le risque
psychologique et risques psychosociaux
dans les entreprises il ya aussi le
risque de montée des addictions en tous
genres alcool cigarettes etc
on doit d'ailleurs rattaché à cela la
montée qui est assez effrayante de la
consommation de psychotropes que l'on
constate d'ailleurs depuis ces dernières
semaines alors tout ce cela tout ceci
porte un nom ça s'appelle la
désocialisation des personnes en
situation de télétravail et on a
tendance quand même à l'oublier le
travail en présentiel si vous voulez le
fait d'aller sur son lieu de travail
justement
et bien c'est un facteur majeur dans la
socialisation des individus donc en gros
le télétravail n'est pas bon pour la
santé jacques et don et non et c'est
quelque chose qu'on fera se rencontrer
en même temps il faut bien mesurer les
paradoxes du télétravail pour des
personnes qui ont un niveau d'éducation
très élevés qui sont dans le bonne
condition qu'ils font un travail
intéressant par exemple le basculement
vers le télétravail a été à l'évidence
une opportunité fructueuse de même pour
certaines entreprises dans les
entreprises ou les tâches sont des
tâches qui sont essentiellement des
tâches innovantes
et qui peuvent faire conscience
justement à leurs salariés
de ce point de vue là et bien
effectivement le télétravail a pu être
aussi une bonne opportunité pour la
majorité des travailleurs du tertiaire
comme pour la majorité des entreprises
concernées et bien le télétravail
s'avère être un piège et il faudra donc
certainement à l'avenir
encadrées et limitées très probablement
cette pratique
alors oui pour répondre à votre question
le télétravail et bien non ce n'est pas
bon pour la santé
et cela peut conduire justement à cette
fameuse désocialisation d'une grande
partie des personnes concernées et bien
jacques dans ce cas prenez soin de vous
puisque vous êtes en télé travail et
merci pour cet éclairage à la semaine
prochaine